Phil Collins is still madly in love with  his ex-wife  Collins confirms to ET that he rekindled  things with Orion  it's lovely I'm back with her the singer  gushed the couple stepped out for the  first time at the little dreams  foundation benefit gala in Miami  following an 8-year split and both could  not stop gushing about each other the 65  year old singer confessed we never  really wanted to split we stayed in  touch and we were so close because of  the kids and we kept it sensible we  didn't go the way that a lot of couples  go and that obviously is evident because  we are back together again  et also spoke to oriane who sweetly  added that the two are very happy  together  the against all odds' singers returned  to the stage at the event marked his  first solo concert after a more than  five-year hiatus